on a l'équivalent chez nous dans les
mystères de l'amour alors là vous allez
voir c'est une baston ah bah évidemment
c'est pas américain c'est bien français
ira sur les bons rails pour eux moi ah
bah justement mollo mollo redescende est
un petit peu c'est parti je sais ce
[Musique]
qu'est ce que vous faites les gars là
vous êtes chez mon réglage celui qu'on
veut on va aux cuma s'explique je suis
dépassée et s'est bougé je bouge tout
essayé jaune
préfère
je suis restée
un jeune jeanne par contre alors par
contre le coup de genou dans les yeux
que c'était bien faire et on attend du
d'ailleurs c'est quand on a si ça mais
bon il fallait que j'ai aimé c'est la
maison elle est sublime sa fille céline
auriez-vous dans cette série non pas
celle là cela mais vous le soleil le
joue gros ses 17 ans et vous vous noyez
font pas faire d'action étrangement
c'est n'est pas de bagarre quel est
votre rôle déjà alors je m'appelle
victor je ne sais pas si le cousin du go
qui a été fait partie de la série suite
à des problèmes de justice intègre la
série à partir de samedi
alors la gare est regardée hamon avait
dénoncé vendredi prochain
[Rires]
sa main quand c'est surtout pas que l'on
se trouve
c'est beau c'est mieux de loin on éviter
ça